what happened to the 11.2 million in
stolen jewels about ten pieces were
taken and that could include the gold
necklaces and rings Kim wore that were
designed by Kanye but the biggest loss
is that giant 20 carat diamond
engagement ring these diamonds would be
almost impossible to sell because of the
size and the rarity and the quality I
mean diamonds of this quality our laser
inscribed it can be removed if a stone
has we polished but even if they're
recut they lose a lot of value another
theory is that the jewels will end up on
a secret black market you would think
that somebody who went to this type of
effort and this type of organization
would already have a source a specific
buyer who may have asked them to take
the items so they may never see the
light of day also stolen was one of
Kim's cellphones now we're told that it
couldn't be cracked and she already was
able to wipe it clean remotely so
there's nothing on her phone that could
be leaked him has always been really
careful of what she puts on our iCloud
what she leaves on her phone just in
case something like this ever did happen
any major lab where somebody would
utilize let's say that these stones were
recut for some reason they would
probably have to be resubmitted to a
major lab for a lab report in order to
state that they are again d-flawless and
that they are type 2a and most anybody
who's going to want to handle those in
the future will want documentation